in high school the days tend to blend
together after a while math test
unrequited love annoying group project
stress rinse repeat sometimes a big
football game or a school dance or maybe
a fight in the hallway breaks up the
monotony a bit but it's normally pretty
uneventful that's always fine by me i've
never tried to be a popular kid or the
center of attention i prefer to keep my
head down work stage crew for the school
plays and just hang out with the same
small group of friends i've known since
we were little kids it was on one of
those ordinary days in a long line of
similarly ordinary days that something
came to destroy the peaceful high school
existence i'd gotten used to as i sat in
history class passing notes with my best
friend zach and ignoring a video about
the civil war i had no idea that i was
about to live through the worst day of
my life and i would be one of the lucky
ones i'd survive the others
let's just say they wouldn't be so lucky
i was just scribbling a response to zack
something about hanging out and playing
xbox after school when the pa system
crackled to life our principal's voice
cut through the droning narration about
the battle of ante time as he spoke
staff this is a lockdown initiate your
lockdown procedures immediately if
you're a visitor outside the building
please leave the property immediately
and call
i assumed it was just another lockdown
drill until i saw my teacher's face she
looked pale her expression tight like
she was trying to hold it together for
our benefit i could see her hand shaking
as she reached to turn off the video
when i heard the tremor in her voice i
knew for sure she was terrified this was
not a drill as our teacher locked the
door and we all climbed under our desk
to crouch in the dark and wait out the
lockdown i could hear my classmates
whispering furvishly everyone was trying
to figure out what was going on someone
suggested a kid had brought a knife to
school someone wondered aloud if a
threat had been called into the
principal's office zach cracked a dumb
joke about a mutated frog escaping from
the biology lab when suddenly a scream
rang out at going down the hall have you
ever felt an entire room of people
holding their breath at once i have we
listened for the sound of fighting for
gunshots anything nothing and then
another scream louder closer and longer
than the last it was the scream of pure
unadulterated fear and pain that
dissolved into a wet gurgle that made my
stomach turn zach and i shared a look
one that said whatever's going on it's
like nothing we've ever seen before i
could feel my chest tightening and it
was getting harder to breathe i tucked
my head between my knees holding on to
the back of my head and trying to take
in deep gulps of air the room felt as if
it tilted on its side and i thought i
might pass out another sound brought me
back to earth it was coming from the
back wall of the classroom by the
chalkboard the sound of liquids sloshing
onto the floor mixed with plaster
splintering apart and pieces clattering
all over i tried to get a better look
but the room was dark and i didn't want
to leave the relative safety of my desk
if there was someone or something coming
into the room i didn't want it to see me
zach had a better angle than me i could
see him craning his neck to get a better
look when he clasped a hand over his
mouth in shock i heard him scream
muffled against his hand what had he
seen what was it before i could even ask
my teacher's cry rippled through the
darkness and the silence get out get out
she repeated over and over again and i
could hear the raw desperation in her
voice it was like someone ushering
passengers off of the sinking titanic
someone who knows there is no hope for
them but hopes they can at least save
the children before it all goes down run
for the love of god just run her voice
broke from fear from pain or both and
the sound was enough to get my legs
working again my classmates had the same
response and we blindly rushed for the
door flipping over desks and knocking
chairs to the side as we scrambled for
an exit zack grabbed my arm and i held
on tight afraid i would lose him in the
chaos someone unlocked the door and we
poured into the hall just as i made it
out of the door i couldn't help but turn
back and look call it morbid curiosity
call it instinct called stupidity but i
had to see what happened i turned just
in time to see a nightmare brought to
life the wall was melting covered in
something thick black and putrid the
smell invaded my nostrils and i gagged
on it her wretched gray arm had its
fingers wrapped around the teacher's
wrist skin peeling off to reveal muscle
and bone it looked like it belonged to a
corpse but it gripped her with inhuman
strength she was pulling with all her
might but i watched helplessly as the
arm pulled her into the melted wall like
she weighed nothing swallowing her body
and her screams with it and then she was
gone zach tucked on my arm hard yanking
me into the hall come on man run he
hadn't seen what i'd seen or he would
have realized that running might not be
enough whatever this thing was it didn't
play by any rules i knew running was all
we had right now though so we ran i
looked around for a weapon something
anything i could use to defend myself
but i couldn't see anything that would
help instead all i saw was the
destruction the intruder had left in its
wake all around me the halls i walked
through every day were falling to pieces
they weren't just damaged they were
coming apart at the seams lockers were
warped beyond recognition walls
completely dissolved sections of the
floor reduced to sizzling puddles of goo
and everywhere everything was covered in
that same black slime it smelled worse
than you could ever imagine it smelled
like the complete loss of hope at the
point of no return it smelled like death
we reached the end of the hall when i
heard something shifting behind us i
suddenly became aware that we were alone
the sound of frantic footsteps hushed
whispers doors slamming shut and locking
had all quieted where was everyone i
glanced over my shoulder and saw one
lone figure shambling down the hall
towards us it was far away and i could
scarcely make it out in the darkness but
i could hear dripping sizzling and the
smell of decay growing stronger that was
not a classmate or a teacher whatever it
was it was taking people away or killing
them i didn't know exactly what but
whatever it was doing to everyone zack
and i were next on its list the scariest
part was how slowly it moved maybe its
legs were too rotten to move any faster
joints disintegrating into useless mush
but it seemed more deliberate than that
to me in my panic clouded mind it seemed
that it was just taking its time it
didn't need to rush and knew that when
it wanted to catch its prey it would i
couldn't suppress the sick feeling in my
stomach this time i keeled over and
vomited onto the floor when i looked up
zach was beckoning me from just inside
the doors to the auditorium come on in
here he could have left me behind for
the intruder to take tried to save
himself and sacrifice the slow friend
frozen in place with terror but here he
was looking out for me again even in
this horrible situation i felt a surge
of gratitude i booked it across the
floor forgetting for a moment about the
shuffling corpse making its way towards
us and joined my best friend in the
auditorium it was eerie in the dark the
curtains soaking up and dampening sounds
barely any light illuminating the
normally cheerful props and backdrops
left from a recent production of alice
in wonderland a once friendly place felt
twisted like a mockery of wonderland
with a monster stalking outside and
waiting to pounce we sat on the stage
listening to the sound of our labored
breathing the air felt heavy but i
welcomed the smell of paint and dust
over the nauseating stench that
permeated the rest of the school
are we the only ones left zach whispered
breaking the silence he was the first
one to say what we were both thinking
what we both feared no
i said with false confidence i think
some of them got out before i couldn't
finish the sentence somebody had to get
out it can't just be us i lean my head
against a giant paper mache toadstool
thought it was too dark for zach to see
the tears filling my eyes what was that
thing he asked did you see it i sat up
straighter i thought i was the only one
who got in a look at this thing however
fleeting no but i i heard it and smelled
it he coughed it took me a while to
answer his question eventually i found
the word it's evil we sat in silence for
a long while after that i don't know
exactly how long moments like that where
at any second you could be lost forever
time stretches out into something
unrecognizable i was starting to think
foolishly that we might be in the clear
when i heard a strange sound it was a
creaking like footsteps on an old wooden
floor i looked around for the source of
the noise but i couldn't see anything it
sounded close impossibly close creek
creek
one step then another where was that
coming from there's no wood floor in the
hall nothing above us by the time i
understood it was too late the top of a
head slimy clammy and gray with tufts of
limp white hair clinging to the soft
flesh began to emerge from the stage
where we sat eyes hollow and dead but
somehow alert and searching for us came
next followed by a gaping wound where a
nose should be and a wide toothless grin
it looked almost like a person but it
was wrong just wrong every cell in my
body rejected it screaming at me with
thousands of years of animal instinct
that i had to run i grabbed zack's arm
and yanked but he didn't come with me i
turned to look and my heart jumped into
my throat it had him his bony fingers i
had a hold on his legs and he was
already halfway gone pulled into the
slick black puddle in the stage
his face was damp with tears as the
reality of his fate set in he grabbed my
hand in his and squeezed run was all he
could get out before the old man pulled
him out of sight so i obeyed my best
friend's wish i ran and i hid in the
prop closet hand over my mouth to stifle
my breathing suddenly there was a loud
bang and i heard voices yelling
something that sounded like a gunshot a
blast of bright light and a voice mail
and official sounding called out is
anyone in here you can come out we're
with the police i opened the closet door
and peered out to see hazmat suits
wielding bizarre weapons and carrying
devices i'd never seen before the man
who had spoken approached me took my
hand and asked me if i'd seen anything i
got the strong sense that i should
definitely not tell him what i'd seen uh
no sir i said he nodded whether he
believed me or not he knew i wouldn't
say anything more gas leak he said
destroy large parts of the building
highly dangerous we need to get you out
of here they took me home and i hugged
my parents tighter than i ever had
before that night the news covered the
tragedy at my school the gas leak had
taken dozens of lives before the
authorities had gotten there everyone
else can accept the story all they want
i know the truth i see it when i close
my eyes imagine it standing over me when
i wake up in the dead of night those
hollow eyes that horrible smile the
stench of death and rot it looked right
at me it saw me it wanted i can't let
myself think about what it wanted i
don't know exactly what i saw but i know
a few things for certain there was no
gas leak zach and the rest of the people
it took are gone and if that monster
ever escapes it's coming after me next
now go check out
scp-106 the old man escape and
scp-106 the old man origin theories for
more explorations into the nightmare
factory that is scp-106